welcome everybody to another episode of
the h3 podcast live today our episode is
sponsored by D brand seat geek naturebox
and of course h3 h3 shop comm today we
have the illustrious video game donkey
and léa léa B via BX I don't know how
specific I need to get next week we are
having kripparrian the twitch streamer
and hardcore gamer oh I need to put up a
thread so you guys can leave your
questions for him I haven't done that
yet I don't know how to scream at to
make that happen probably just myself
but in the meantime and before we get
into that next week we have got these
two legends here now dunkey who is I'm
looking at his back right now they
didn't want to make it awkward for me
because I was gonna do an intro and
usually they guess walk in but they're
like well we're here already can you
show the wide so they're just sitting
here and their backs are facing me I
feel like of the Blair Witch Project
they're really committed to it - video
game donkey no one makes videos like
this guy he's a one-of-a-kind
masterpiece how did I do he's known for
her loving spaghetti and meatballs or
not and he is also black yeah nobody
knows if he likes it but he I think he
likes it
he's a man he's so powerful he was
blacklisted from playing League of
Legends forever which is a badge of
honor if you ask me and probably he
would agree Lea his care also as a
channel Lea be where they make vlogs and
cute videos and now I present to you my
friends the illustrious and the
wonderful Jason and Lea thank you guys
it's really nice to have you here it's
so cool thanks
going yeah thank you for inviting us
yeah I feel like you're elusive in a way
because your your videos are so prolific
but your character is kind of elusive so
it's really cool to have you in here and
see what's the deal why does everyone
think you're but I am okay he would like
right in little clips of his face he
wouldn't say like hey this is me and
then people just like heard the voice
and they were like that's got to be a
black guy you know what's funny I
thought you thought - oh my god I was
sure you would fly I don't know why and
then I saw your dancing video that you
did for like you did some like subscribe
is it maybe a million or something was
it the one it was all snowy yeah yeah
looks freezing it was very jubilant I'm
a confused
Talmud's kids yeah did anyone recognize
you when you're shooting that no I don't
know why yeah I thought you were black
for the longest time and I was like oh
my god stop like I guess it's the voice
he's got kind of right got like a Louis
Armstrong thing nothing there master
yeah jazzy voice good lord well we've
got some some wonderful things here too
to celebrate today today is mining Ellis
five-year anniversary thank you so much
and we were at Disneyland yesterday with
these two guys
celebrating our engagement yeah first
announcement congrats tell me about tell
me give me the details at the post
office romances began yeah I had to ship
some packages and I came back out to the
car yep and he just said look in the
glove box and I was like why I don't
know if that's I think that's even
better than putting or like more
romantic possibly than we see it you
have it on yeah can we get a shot if you
like actually was good because it
surprised me because we were coming on
this big trip so I would have guessed
you'd like do it at Disney sometime but
that would have been expected so you
know it was a surprise in the car okay
but you guys planned a vacation mm-hmm
but who planned it because was it
because of the engagement we planned it
for my birthday well [ __ ] was on Sunday
oh happy birthday like a double
celebration yeah damn cold still cold
heart
there was someone on Twitter actually I
wanted to shout her out because she like
noticed when we posted our picture
yesterday at Disney she saw that Jason's
wearing the button and she saw my ring
like really tiny in the photo and she
was like they got engaged I was the only
like on it I liked it good job that move
like get me into the yeah we had like
talked about you know getting engaged
like sometime within the year yeah you
had you had hope so that's what I mean
that's what I was talking about where it
Disney it's like look we both knew they
were gonna say yes we don't need to get
on horseback and do all this that's for
insecure guys who are like I'm going to
spend a bunch of money to put the peer
pressure on them so they can't say no
because I spent $100,000 on that
romantic that's right love is putting it
in a bag of baby wipes I think some
girls out there do yeah they want your
like moment they want to feel like you
know the most special moment but that
ain't any with some people is just like
a mutual you know yeah yeah I guess
that's fair I like your opinion where
you don't actually have to hate on
people who think differently horses are
special [ __ ] you gotta feed them
[Laughter]
honey there's a there here the ring is
in the is in the
box and there's also a dead horse you
may have noticed I was part of this my
wedding gift
thank you horse jerky listen I saw this
tweet today Jason and I just wanted to
know the wicked wolf had said today's
the day I finally unsubscribed from your
channel you're a complete [ __ ]
imbecile that's a shame what happened it
was a big he's gone he's what was it
about the new video I didn't see
anything controversial about it did you
watch it yeah I didn't think it was
controversial either it really likes
those Tekken 1 cinematics I don't know
if he's out there just do a follow-up
what happened yeah it wasn't about it
yeah I'd like to know more to tell me uh
how was your relationship with your fans
do you see a lot of reactions like that
he complains a lot about like people not
getting his intention what is like kind
of frustrating like which video in
particular well this one I kind of like
confused what I'm trying to get it
mm-hmm because a lot of times you do
something that's kind of a parody and
then there's kind of not and kind of
like there's a lot of layers to it so I
[ __ ] maybe for some people it's easy to
like miss the point one thing I found on
YouTube is like you can't be too sore
it's hard to be subtle you have to like
hit people over the head with a club
because I think a lot of the people who
write comments like they'll write it cuz
they were like either didn't like it or
they were confused but if people were
just like oh okay yeah cool then they'll
just move on they're just really great
the combination I got it like Jimmy
Collins ever get to you Oh
never he's so like he has a thick skin
about that comment that's good I'm more
like offended by some comments sometimes
but but you seem like you wanna get sued
he's like why are you looking like just
ignore it but it's such a it's so messed
up because like you were saying most of
them are good see you have a healthy
view of it and my thing is like and I
know it's sick but I'll be look I'll
look at the comments and I'm trying just
not to read them anymore because it's it
but it's like I'll skim pass like all
like ten of the nicest things anyone
ever said about me and then one guy was
like [ __ ] you buddy that's kind of and
I'm aware of that some eight-year-old is
like getting funny thing for like my
channel and stuff to my mom like reads
every cop Oh Mike she's like getting
deeper than me she reads all of them and
I don't I can't
did she ever text and be like I saw this
today and I just wanted to tell you one
of the talked about it yeah I don't know
she's texting me but she definitely
brings it up like when I go visit my
daddy's commenting nasty stuff do your
parents watch your videos uh-huh
I think so do their mom we used to kill
the missions where you swearing in these
videos kids they're gonna look it up and
swear she's a good second-grade teacher
oh that's yeah so
so I want to ask you because I'm really
this most people on YouTube I watch
their videos and I understand how
they're made like I understand somewhat
the creative process of what's going on
there and but with you I don't really
understand how you make those videos
that you do like do you record tons of
footage and then voiceover or later do
you do voiceover while you're playing
the game you just sometimes like how
does that work it's it's always
different sometimes I'll write a script
sometimes on this record three minutes
okay so you're just when you do that are
you looking for like a specific like
shot or you're just like oh that
happened and that was funny
I'm gonna say like like a montage just
like overwatch video or a league one no
just say I'll try to cut out the
funniest parts mmm overwatch feels like
it takes like months now to just to get
four minutes of entertaining stuff one
game yeah like what can I do anymore
what does that mean what does that say
about over welcome to the [ __ ] ocean
second you have massive hard drives you
have such a good system where like oh
yeah you gotta use fraps okay okay every
game fraps and then every time something
happens you hit the button so you know
to look at the end of the then you're
going through like 3000 clips you just
skip to the end every time huh that's
brilliant yeah and he has to clean it
out so it's not like you know his whole
computer's always fall though usually
every day yeah I there's a bag of
Cheetos on the desk just like Cheetos
all over the
so I've always had trouble desktop
recording I don't know what's going on
in my life but I'm having multiple
computers multiple programs I've used
like Camtasia it sounds awful right I
mean the name so there's so many tears
what am I doing wrong for like a game
anything recording YouTube well you know
if you record with like bandicam
and HD I add it with Adobe and if you
put HD [ __ ] you can't edit it it's like
it'll take like a minute to respond
that's just it's like undoable I just do
like fake HD like 70 yeah cuz you putz
it all up anyway the video as long as it
says HD en XD there you go it's a funny
idea for a video super 4k you can come
over and set it up for you at your oh
yeah
what program do you use to edit I do
yeah it's a love/hate yeah do you
wrestle with with premiere a lot
yeah it's sometimes yeah yeah [ __ ] well
that'll just what the [ __ ] yeah it just
that's what the [ __ ] happened yeah like
what I'm dealing with now is that when I
make a keyframe it will just randomly
twist hmm for no reason there's a twist
in it so I'll go like at this image to
go to aid to be and then it's just like
i'ma go in a [ __ ] rainbow and go up
this green yeah between the keyframes
instead of a straight line I don't know
why I'm just like what
it's a learning curve
seventy years you get to understand the
quirks often feel like in Premiere I'm
you have to like outsmart the bugs like
a sink whant a sequence were like not
work will be something wrong so ok I
need to create a new sequence change the
settings to 720 put that in there
restart my computer five times that's
the solution on the official forum so
when you're editing you have all this
footage do you just like painstakingly
go through all this stuff or do you have
an idea afterwards you're like using
that trick you said or do you just watch
like hours and hours of footage I mean I
watched it so much that one of the ideas
happened then but sometimes I'll add it
all the guidance a [ __ ] sucks
you do it all you scrap videos a lot ah
really anymore
I just try to think everything out now
mmm nice time on the back burner I got
ahead enough but I didn't so I save it
for later I see him do a lot that's cool
like the video you posted today about
the bad graphics that apparently caused
the exodus like you mentioned that you
had been working on that for a while so
tell me like about how that video came
to be I just started writing like a
little script and notepad like last
month mmm I can't think thank this
through I can't get it all together so
just wait till later and then later you
find like you just think about it you
don't like a different way to sometimes
like the timings off too like you got to
get a new video out mmm this one will
take too long I'd be on time
yeah yeah when a new heart
like is out were you just like grind for
16 hours will you let the crazy
cuphead I'm still okay you have a cup
head video coming yeah so a lot of
people were asking because we have a
thread video bed no comment for now
you'll have to watch yeah we have to
like plan our trips around like game
release schedules and excited for that
you got to stay home from reo you can't
go anywhere take everything off the
calendar my favorite video of yours I
think or one of them is the Skyrim one
with just all the insane mods colliding
like tell me about the process of how
you you that video came to be I mean I
think that was just like seeing on
everywhere you're going to just see like
people just posting mods Skyrim just
like the shittiest monster the dumbest
[ __ ] ever there's so many people just I
just wanted to see like how much that
[ __ ] I can enable at once
everything you can enable everything at
once it seems like like a supercomputer
like a prebuilt one it's a predator
Jason so basically you started from just
this point of like I want to throw all
these in it see what happen and it was
it was such a joyous I freaking love
that video
his first when they got to the top of
Reddit I think really really no it's
kind of like a breakthrough
like their mom stuffy what's that cool
for you yeah I think that brought in
some new people
mm-hmm do you use read it yeah I look
down there sometimes say like comments
sometimes sometimes there's some smart
stuff on there clever stuff and
sometimes it's like worse than YouTube
huh yeah it's true I don't know when and
where to look so I just stopped looking
honestly oh you don't like it we try not
to look yeah yeah I think that 1:19 look
at the comments didn't read them at all
not because the thing is like I need to
make the conscious choice because I know
people like that video so I need to
decide do comments affect me or not I
can't look at them when they're good and
then not look at them when they're bad
I'm gonna want to look like either way
and I don't want to look at the comments
on a video that's like mediocre because
everyone's just gonna be like super rude
and like heavy I'm like yeah it wasn't
the best video but you don't need to
[ __ ] like can't eat my children about
it and so for me I'm like I can't like
pick and choose when I'm reading it
needs to be all or nothing right yeah it
definitely can reduce your stress a lot
if you decide I'm done like looking at
yeah it's I read every single and you're
not super depressed all the time I know
it doesn't take any effort to write them
income you know to see someone put an
effort right now it was really nice
uplifting comments that's really good
dude god bless you man seriously we
should maybe I should do that yeah
that's actually really cool we used to
do that YouTube is like introducing like
a filter now like a censors thing did
you see that no I think so
I get blocks comments now I feel like
they're just typing then like the n-word
or some [ __ ]
do you have that on
yeah I think it helps mm-hm I mean
should I hope with us I hope it works
it's kind of like I always wonder like
should I sense should I block certain
comments or just leave it all open it's
like it's like not a free speech thing
it's like just I don't need people
screaming the N word in the comments
like the world was not losing anything I
don't know I used to think like that all
right I don't need a bunch to deal yeah
what do you delete on your studies don't
think oh you should never delete any all
right thank ya so when you delete a
comment like when you decide this one it
just gets me angry it's like the dumb
especially if it's a really long one
that's like [ __ ] you just wasted all
that time do you block because you can
mine are you banned I'm black right now
spam one like hey it's me donkey and it
has my [ __ ] picture go on this link
and it's like a virus and [ __ ] then
there's like a comment why'd you send
this to me well to be fair you give him
a virus I totally understand where he's
coming from what's your favorite types
of videos to make it's like something
new something that doesn't like super
formulaic
he just made like a movie review he like
The Shining one it was great school
thank you I enjoyed that a lot dude and
I think you're fancy too because again
one of the top question was like are you
gonna do more movie reviews do
other kinds of reviews necessarily
before movie stuff on YouTube
I see like a lot of those movie YouTube
channels they get in trouble what's real
that's copyright stuff yeah less so with
video game stuff yeah
like video games I don't know I feel
like you can usually get away with it
Nintendo will sometimes crackdown but
even then you know a lot of Nintendo
stuff will still get through and make
money I was gonna ask you because I
heard about this Nintendo thing they
when did they do this and make this new
policy forever ago really I think I was
like two or three years ago what was it
they just take all the like if you have
a Nintendo song game they'll just take
all the money I don't know it seems
self-defeating like it's not much money
for Nintendo that's like so much
promotion so little money they're
trading like ten bucks yeah a hundred
million views I'm free promotion which
is pretty much what you make on YouTube
these days did you stop making like
Nintendo related content as a result are
you still doing your thing no I'm still
doing it cool well let's take a quick
break to thank our sponsors and we will
be back after this short thank you to
the boys stay tuned and now a quick
thank you to our wonderful sponsors
beginning with DD brand nice D brand is
an incredible company a big fan of that
I am a big fan of and they're a big
supporter of ours and creators in
general they make this product it's like
a decal that basically transforms your
phone into a whole new slammin hot item
um show the website here you can
basically customize your phone they've
got uh decals for every type of foam
wood it looks so genuine you know metal
and everyone's favorite green eye
previously had the marble marbles great
stones really cool I mean it looks
genuine and it really it does protect
the phone
without the bulk of a case if that's not
what it you're into but today I am here
to talk to you about their upcoming
product which is a phone case called
grip look at this
basically grip answers the question here
while most competitors are doing well
most competitors aim to one-up their
competition on drop test they're looking
answer the question how do we stop
phones from dropping in the first dang
place you know chicken or egg
they say egg the grip does exactly that
gives you confidence that you're not
going to drop your device that said if
you do it still got world-class impact
protection technology built-in guys okay
I'm actually really hyped for this
I'm 100% gonna get this when it comes
out if you guys want to sign up for the
newsletter go down to the bottom right
put in your dang email and you'll get
notified when this hot slam and baby
comes out soon and I'm definitely gonna
be hyping this when it comes out I got
this cute little video here it's a race
car it's driving it's slammin it's
shifting it's all over the track and
then a whole sudden oh my god you will
not believe what you're about to see the
phone I was on the car the whole flippin
time now frankly I don't know you know
probably not a practical use but it it
shows you how serious business this is
so guys head on over to Dee brand.com
slash grip and let him know that you're
gripping that you're gripping so thank
you to D Brown for supporting the show
and I'm looking forward to that new that
new case and next up I love these guys
seeking because they don't seek keep by
the way is a website that aggregates
tickets to live events from all over the
world to make buying simple now we all
know they have a great product and a
great website but what didn't we know is
that they're good ask great ask people
my brother or my sister my dad have like
a combined birthday in September their
birthday
very close to each other and they're
both huge Dodger tickets and I hit him
up and I'm like can you guys hook up my
my dad and my sister for for the Dodger
game coming up it was it was Game one of
the playoffs and they're super excited
it was sold out so that can you can you
do anything for me and look at this look
at what they did for my family look at
these [ __ ] seats dugout right behind
first base first base I don't think
about baseball but basically this the
best seats they've ever had they were so
happy and I was so thrilled that that we
were able to hook him up and seek he
just Pony tup and good guy seat geek
apparently it's like a whole different
adventure back there they've like free
buffets yeah memorabilia a complete
experience there's apparently like crab
claws just stacked high on ice and you
disappear entirety people live there
just like Oh claw for the go
it's like go-gurt so anyway SeatGeek I
just wanted to give them a real big
thank you to these guys
I was super nice to them basically how
it works is they give you a 0-200 score
on his ticket to let you know how good
of a deal you're getting or if it's a
bad one we're green equals good bad
equals a red so you know um you know I'm
compromising this one's not as good of a
deal but I really want to see it or hey
this is a great value in the app you can
get a view from your seat so you know
where you're gonna sit you know what
you're getting yourself into
is it a great seat is it a nosebleed
you'll find out right away guess what
go to seat geek comm link in the
description the game app and use code h3
h4 you guys you got to download the app
use code h2 h3 and get $20 off your
first order click the link in
description below to download the app
code h3 h3 god bless you see geek you
sweet sweet ass Fox and who's next some
brands don't like me to curse in their
spots but
hopefully they don't mind I do it to
highlight how much I love you
goddamnit thank you see kook and lastly
we've got naturebox who I love because
it helps me cultivate Fupa I get thick
and voluptuous and beautiful and you
know what they do their best to prevent
that because their whole thing is that
they make snacks that are delicious and
nutritious and don't have a billion
calories but guess what when you eat as
much as me that doesn't really matter
cuz it's so frickin good you're not
American unless you crack open three
bags of snacks in one sitting nature box
has over a hundred snacks that taste
good and are actually better for you all
snacks are made from a high-quality
simple ingredients which means no
artificial colors flavors or sweeteners
so you can feel good about what you're
eating and boy let me tell you I feel
good probably better than I should look
at this their snacks are off the chain
probiotic power mix that means it makes
your butthole healthy yeah I think or
stomach yeah why not say well you know
it's all it's all tied together eula
tried mango pineapple vanilla bean
wafers this is my favorite the sriracha
roasted cashews those well take you on
an adventure a whole new ride it's like
a ladder when he was on the magic carpet
that's what these cashews are for you
spiritually and emotionally cheddar
cheese crisps are you kidding me dark
cocoa nom noms you put nom nom in the
title and you expect me not to buy it
there's hundreds of these okay they
basically you know you're sure to find
your snack obsession at naturebox they
had new snacks every month inspired by
real feedback the latest food trends and
professional chefs it's simple guys go
to nature box calms twos the snacks you
want a nature box will deliver them
right to your damn door your goddamn
door and there's no risk
you ever try snack you don't like don't
eat it because nature box will replace
it for free so check it out goodnight
con /h Street right
go right now right now to naturebox calm
dance get 50% off their first order what
did I say wrong the first thing you
didn't say this / oh you guys wash it
yes naturebox calm
order man naturebox calm
we all eat snacks this is a better place
to do it folks so thank you to our
sponsors to seek geek D brand in nature
box if you're in the market for any of
those support the show by hitting them
up and finally just a little promotion
here new shirts in the h3 h3 shop calm
because YouTube has demonetised our
channel and now this is our new source
of making Adsense selling shirts but
luckily we're on fire this is a vintage
vapenation shirt that is sure to explode
your game and get you cultivate Fupa get
get you know touch of vagina
I don't know this shirt will enable
whatever it is you dream up doing and
more go to h3 shop calm and pick
yourself one up today thank you guys for
sitting through that and now back to
video game donkey and Leah welcome back
with the illustrious and prolific video
game donkey and Leah can you guys please
join as we did the reads we made them
face the wall so that it was less
awkward so tell me who in your opinion
makes the best games Nintendo a lot of
good indie guys there's so many good
someone hungry guys out there trying to
make good [ __ ] it's a lot of competition
right and then a lot of more competitive
than ever for the Indies yeah yeah
the games are crazy but if you go to
like the conventions like packs stuff
like that the Indy section is always
like the best part of any convention
like more so than you know the big
companies just more interesting more
experimental yeah we get to play the
games yeah they're like right there
that's awesome yeah do you what do you
think about Nintendo as a company
because I actually agree they make the
best games but like this [ __ ] on YouTube
it's just like so they're like what
they're so out of touch right it's like
just everything like in what way
they still don't know how to do Internet
at all like you have to do it [ __ ] 17
digit friend code instead of just add in
somebody's name and like product
launches they never make enough yeah
it's not it's like they're selling
diamonds make more switchers
shout out to you guys I can get a switch
yeah sweet ass Fox we're like I just
bought an extra one I'll mail it to you
it's like send me a switch I guess that
explains why Nintendo is so like oh you
can't use our games on YouTube they're
just out of touch you think that's what
I think it's like the switch you know of
course they want to make more but they
just don't I guess they don't have the
production manufacturing yeah but why
not you'd think they could get as much
as they want
yeah high standards or something yeah so
what is it about them that they make the
best games like do they have a
philosophy or something I mean what is
going on they're like they just have all
the most talented dudes like it's got
all Japanese dudes this they take their
work so seriously I think this is that
culture it's like that honor yeah that
deep ancient honor because it's so
serious god bless him like I remember I
read a thing about Sonic 2 like they try
to stay co-developed it and they had
like you know they brought in Jeff and
workers and American workers and
American guys are just [ __ ] off
goofing around the Japanese guys taking
this so seriously track their hardest to
make the best game ever you think I love
that down away cuz it's like you're
making a video game show like oh this is
my dream I'm video game but for them
they're like I will start by the samurai
sword this is the best game of the
decade got it yeah maybe that's it let's
take a call country boy 420 I love that
name it's like a little incestual it's a
little 420 what do you got for me wait
what happened we got to make sure this
where do you go
o country boy where'd you go I think I
moved country more 420 to the wrong
channel can you help me get his ass in
there thank you boy for 20 community
such as gaming when it's kind of a kind
of like over done I guess like how do
you like different she I guess from all
the other channels cool nice thanks Doug
just try I don't want you to plug DJ in
full plug DJ in sole unfold god dammit
hey man how are you good good how are
you guys
we're great good all right my question
is for for all of you um
you're both collaborators with your
significant others what is that
experience like is it rough at times
what are the main points of having each
other's presence when creating content a
wonderful question HS no problem you
guys want to take you guys to that one I
remember the Pokemon one Lea was very
hot it was really hot it's getting
frustrating come on go yeah and it's
like yeah I'm doing all this stupid [ __ ]
but she's filming it yeah so what's more
uncomfortable you know people give me
the dirty looks like my throwing
pokeballs at people and [ __ ]
she's like over there filming it yes you
guys are kindred spirit you know what
you're gone sunk heroes because you
watch these documentaries about these
guys climbing up to Everest for iam shot
with ducks we couldn't find any ducks
and then he ran into this lake going
four in the morning it don't like get
the mist down there you get the Ducks
that's when you got to get the docks so
it's rough when he asked like do his
recording we like have our desks in our
same computer room so it's kind of weird
if I'm like still in there like typing
and linkies in my computer so I like
have to go down I go in like our
basement and like wait till he's done
recording he has to you know I'm getting
his own so you have to work around yeah
the delicate genius I mean like I've
never made videos without her yeah I
don't know how that's been yeah you work
together a lot more than we do I like
for my channel we do everything together
like that then well were you making
videos before you guys work together or
for like how long were you already
making videos I've been making them
since I was like 12
oh wow ooh groans oh you're old school
dude damn that's so cool so in our case
we've been making videos since like day
one so I've never even known separate
thing I mean it's always been like that
cool
operation from the beginning like even
coming up with the ideas and how to do
even editing will still sit together and
I was like it was just funny and she's
like no do you ever be like I mean
sometimes I would say like you should
like put this in yeah take like an
ending league oh yeah yeah I don't know
I thought it was like a bad idea the way
he was doing it Oh like I didn't think
he needed to make like the big like I
don't know we always want to stay out of
yeah giant like the biggest company yeah
because like that was kind of his thing
that built him up was the whole league
thing I was like well you can just phase
it out and not like do the huge but it
ended up being like a fine idea I mean
but did your feelings change over time
now that you've seen the reaction yeah
for sure yeah he was right like but I'm
like she knows more than me like what's
good news channel so sometimes Ethan
will want to talk about something and
we'll kind of stressed me out like you
know I'm about to go on and call the
president that was a joke cast a
reference not an actual threaded no
intention of hurting anybody but
sometimes yeah go back to my point
yeah a lot of times I would be like no
we shouldn't and then he feels like we
should and then eventually it was right
you know so but it's important yeah you
know both sides you know because if I'm
getting too gung-ho in my head yeah it's
like the you know the devil names yeah I
like just ringing it in
yeah like think about it what you're
doing yeah yeah I want to ask you about
that League video I love that hole I
personally love the way you're just like
[ __ ] these guys I guess maybe just
resonates with me because I'm a very
much really identify with how they're
just like just kicked your ass to the
curb after you've promoted them for so
long you know like you still think about
that you stole are you upset at them it
was a two week ban like they banned him
forever yeah you were you had like a
world might have been like a five day
suspension okay it was just the last
straw though yeah yeah yeah
they were really weird like just that
everyone talks about him they said they
like they have such a strict you know
how they enforce it and it had been like
building up for a while and he had done
like weird things with them in the past
right like what though you made some
videos for them and they like just
didn't use it that's what tell me about
it well it was actually a fun thing they
did they were like they were gonna show
one of my videos at the big tournament
thing hmm and they had me make like five
videos just like no that's not gonna
work that's not gonna like two or three
weeks like now that's not gonna work and
they picked like the least offensive one
what did they expect pretty cool but did
they did the other four ever get to see
the light of day and put those up okay
good yeah at least that that's so I
don't know what do you think about right
as a company are you just over it yes I
don't really see people guys that did
videos on it and like
with it now yeah it died out yeah you
were kind of a catalyst I think the
downfall of like the holy you tube did
you kill League but seriously do you cuz
I feel like League has waned a lot in
popularity I mean specifically from the
moment when you're like I'm not gonna
play this game anymore
yeah that's what it feels like that's
dead I don't know if that's true but it
seems like it on YouTube I still see it
like on Twitch it has some of the
highest numbers but still I mean it's I
think it's more like professional guys
now I like guys take it really seriously
are really good but it's funny okay I
think you you just sensed that it was
like timed it out like you'd been doing
it for like four years or something yeah
I think yeah I mean you really like that
collaboration I do miss them like you
know I'd bring and she would be playing
all my friends you know I try to include
everybody in the video it seems like
nowadays just to play all together with
a group like that thanks
what was the one where you put me and
John it was a counter-strike one right
I was overwatch I was yeah you're like
you didn't even tell us you're recording
did your play dota yeah yeah what do you
think
oh that's impenetrable it's so hard to
get into I have like 2,000 hours clock
but just pretty much what you need to be
like I kind of understand that's like is
there a what what competitive game are
you playing these days overwatch just
still fun yeah I think that's
yeah I haven't been playing as much just
been really busy lately but him
especially he's been playing like every
Mario game hmm just preparing for the
new one how are you feeling about the
new Mario game dude it's gonna be the
best game ever made I love your faith in
the the serious ancient mythology of the
Nintendo yeah the whole man thing I feel
like us changing changing hands now I
feel like the Wii U was the trade-off
between the old groove hmm no Zelda did
I have like Zelda NV like I and I want
to play it again for the first time I
love that game so much amazing how many
hours you clocked playing that game they
don't want to show that to you it's like
we could see no it's not though I'm just
trying to do that goofy tricks for that
video you don't see me like you just see
me doing it right I tried to do like 200
times just get the [ __ ] balloon up
there normally again with this balloon
so what's your favorite video that
you've ever made
[Music]
would you have a couple that sound out
as like I am really proud of of how this
came out no he did a purge Oh what does
that mean I really do I just delete old
ones just sucks now hmm his standards
keep going up so I know jontron does
that too and I was always like why are
you doing this man it has like three
million views why are you killing this
do you delete videos with lots of views
on it Oh
no not really I don't think just on
private just like older ones that
nobody's singing just unless them so I
went back and saw your oldest video was
like Battletoads 1 so that wasn't your
first video it's really good
older channel-to-channel what does it
[Music]
mean face I like phase dunkey I want you
to be in phase claim I think they'll
take him if not we'll start around we'll
call it face this is this is Jason's
official application to the face class
you guys are watching please get back to
us so what what inspired you to make
videos ah I guess like back on
Newgrounds you know mmm just see like
all those goofy cartoons on the Internet
Wow I want to do that make something
like that of course that old you guys
remember that new ground stuff yeah
Edgar dance hell yeah all that stupid
old [ __ ] that's when we were kids and
that was cool that was amazing it was
the coolest and most amazing thing in
the world
yeah I could you can make so you want it
to be an animator originally I guess so
I was such a bad animators he had some
good ones he had like a series with
Admiral Ackbar okay and him and his
friends was like voices
they were like 10 years yeah that's what
I was gonna actually do for my next
video with comfort I was gonna talk
about all that stuff so I'll wait I want
to watch it through the lens I remember
I would always be bugging like the guys
like the popular guys from the time they
were so nice like they would just add
you and tell you all the tricks and [ __ ]
I would just sit there and annoy him I'm
just like how did you do this how did
you do this yeah you guys remember
legendary frog he made uh I used to make
like these green guys he made all these
old cartoons they were so good front
page right yeah it was like the spray
today or whatever oh yeah yeah yeah what
the um that was fun did you ever find
success on new ground not only mmm-hmm
kind of oh yeah you do it like a collab
with like ten different guys and like
every day we'd put out a cartoon like
ten of our little shorts
that's not your aunt you're an animator
at heart worst is that relate to your
name somehow the dunkey thing
meatwad sprite which was my name and new
girl
league that was my new girl's name hmm
this is bright like the little no video
wait a sprite is like a little fairy no
it's right and a video game it's like
you know like a picture of Mario he's
like doing this that's right and if he
like changes is saying that's a
different sprite okay so that's like
those old games there'd be like eight
sprites at Mario okay
like the frames of him walk right yeah
god I could frame my animation so where
did the name video game donkey come from
I think I was talking about my friend
Dion he helped me get into you -
big-time mm-hmm
I was just goofing off with him once I
told him the donkey or some told them
yeah and he we're playing left 4 dead
and he was stuck like at the beginning
or something and I kept trapping them in
that's usually how it goes down with me
and him playing I'm just [ __ ] we're
winning the whole experience with him
right and I said like to get out you had
to say go go magic dunk
he would not say that eventually broke
down and and so the name was born
can he help me give them to you - Wow
god bless him you throw him and then he
was a sweet guy paper bat right people
that G yeah I notice you're wearing some
official merch
you guys got to sling some shirts man I
saw people saying I'm worse that I hope
I saw somebody say we were talking about
this yesterday you got a sling merch
there saying I hope dunkey makes shirts
someday and and made by you right yeah
come on you guys
well you can go to the website the link
is at my Twitter which is VG Lea B but
if you want to go directly it's donkeys
castle that looks really cool yeah it
might take a couple weeks to ship with
it head on over to dunky dunky castle
you get some goddamn official Marsh all
right I'm angry about it but you have a
like a comedic influence someone that
you love that embodies the call me that
you type that you love everybody
everyone I talk to is a huge influence
on all my stuff really my friends family
a lot of stolen jokes a lot of people
you know friends like your joke you know
some jokes you tell me off the cuff
those are in their material but there's
not you ready to be the curator
yeah I'm the guy who maps it all
together in a way yeah exactly
that's the talent you're also fun you're
very time let's not I'm funny too that's
really cool though
yeah we crashed your website
oh my god carnal nets can only have
three people on there at a time starting
a keel yeah I could say every five
minutes
and IANS gonna make a queue you have to
get in line to visit donkeys castle okay
check it tomorrow when we post this on
youtube it's gonna be even crazier okay
well I'll do a restock and stuff when we
get home we gotta go back to Wisconsin
we're in California right now I'm asleep
though it'll be a week or two but yeah I
love the homemade thing I used to get to
use the grind for days yeah well you
know it's a personal it's fun it's fun
that's so wholesome I think that's like
honestly the most beautiful answer I've
ever heard and response to that do you
like do you have any professional
comedians that you look up to or growing
up you're like this is the funniest guy
want to be like you know the dudes who
write aquitine I love that when I was a
kid yeah it's so naturalistic like
that's such a weird show Space Ghost
mmm those guys are amazing it's all
Adult Swim right yeah no Timoner generic
big-time I think a lot of youtubers
really I guess yeah I'm inspired by I
think they just came around at like a
perfect time like I remember the first
time I saw them I was in college by
myself and in bedroom was like 3:00 a.m.
I was playing World of Warcraft and it
came on the TV I was like I was like
what is this
at first I was just like shocked just
like oh my god what this [ __ ] on TV and
then you come to love it cuz it's just
so weird and so yeah I remember what
used to what my dad would put them
Space Ghost down when I was a kid I just
had no comprehension what was happening
it's like the most boring cartoon ever
yeah I guess a talk show with a guy is
so boring for a kid yeah listen I don't
like this is the best thing
do you ever would you do a show on Adult
Swim yes ready
I think we could put something together
what would it look like if you had your
own show on Adult Swim I'd be a
cinematic masterpiece cinematic what
would you doing it I'd be you know it'd
be a science-fiction no comedy at all no
dialogue would be about like gorillas
live-action girls
yeah live-action gorillas I'm like
Futuristics post-apocalyptic world by
the way I hope nobody out there is gonna
steal your idea don't swim has the
budget fruit anything with no words
well I listen if anybody from Adult Swim
is watching we have got some fresh
Bradbury's to pick here so that's really
cool see you where do you see yourself
in five years do you see yourself making
them like long-form content on somewhere
else than YouTube or on YouTube are you
pretty happy with the status quo I think
I guess I like this I hope I can keep
doing this for a while he talks about a
lot like if he could make a movie he
would make the best movie ever I think
that's more like a hobby type of do you
write do you write screenplays and stuff
he writes scripts for videos like mini
movies so that is cool I think you would
make the best video I'm just based on
that some Nasus we offer the show
I don't think you could not make a
comedy I think you trying not to make a
comedy would make it funnier yeah be
like the room yeah we've seen it I'm
obsessed with it
this one episode where George is on a
date and he's like Jerry don't be funny
[Laughter]
am I being funny right now so let's
let's switch gears here I want to talk
to you about your dreams games critic
video
oh did I say that right or did have a
stroke game critics video games critics
scream that's right I have dyslexia so
sometimes I jumbled jumbled my [ __ ] are
you surprised by the reaction because
people got generally you made a video
well tell me about the what was the
video about ah game critics they suck
yeah yeah you think we all been was
feeling that look you going I you go on
like Metacritic yeah like you pointed
out but I tried that you know I tried to
come down on the systemic you know
issues just I'm like how the website you
know makes you game critics do [ __ ]
try to not come down on the people you
know but karst all the funniest [ __ ] is
them goofing up because the system is so
shitty right like I Gina's like alright
you got two days to beat Zelda row and
go review it yeah [ __ ] you need like
three months to get through it again you
missed so big yeah you give a real
review you showed that clip of jay-z
which I thought was perfect where he was
talking about music reviews he's like
people putting out album reviews and one
day it's like you can't appreciate that
album one day yeah and a video games
even crazier yeah so long there's so
long short but so were you surprised by
the amount of kickback you got from that
cuz I saw a lot of critics and he took a
gazebo were just like who the [ __ ] is
this guy why the [ __ ] should I care
about a head meanwhile that one was at
the top of Reddit right everyone was
talking about it and they're just like
oh who's this [ __ ] guy who does he
think is like were you surprised by how
they were just like I don't care about
this guy at all
[Music]
I mean all the people liked it yeah I
like the YouTube comments and stuff that
was probably one of like the most
agreeing with him on like issues you
know when he makes it more controversial
one but yeah the critics themselves it
was getting crazy on Twitter
what was like the harshest thing
somebody said about it I don't get
dunkey on a high horse I don't
understand putting a donkey on a high
horse that's fine get that donkey off
the high horse like this [ __ ] sucks
stupid yeah they started ripping I've
never watched this and it sucks yeah
that like proved his point in itself
like I didn't watch the whole video but
I know I just watch the video but I gave
it a 7 out of 10
[Laughter]
was there any reviewers who were cool
about it we were like yeah you you have
a point there was a couple guys that you
know try to actually talk about it mmm I
did come down you know kind of hard on
everyone even though there are some good
guys out there yeah doing good stuff you
think that video had like any effect on
the know the point you made about like
shitty awful video games getting 70s
it's so hero like I went and checked the
Mass Effect Andromeda already call it in
dramatis right like I got a seven 71 or
72 i Metacritic and I just saw footage I
mean I never played the game but I saw
footage and her people thought I was
like oh my god what have they done that
was like my favorite game of course
they'll done was that series yeah it's
like it was born with a birth defect or
something beautiful yeah this game in
life came out like very underway but
yeah I think we all see that I think
your criticism was much needed as much
my very important stuff there
so are there critics that out there that
you
like particularly YouTube guys I watch
out of YouTube Hill game guys Pro Jared
he puts out some really good stunts his
taste is just like the polar opposite of
my interesting so he's like he likes
Final Fantasy and it's like cool to see
him explain you know why he loves the
old NES Final Fantasy and it's like
that's probably the last game I would
ever want to play hmm and he makes it so
you know do you play it after watching
it sometimes but it's awesome to see you
know his viewpoint you know he
illustrates it so good
oh that's cool it's the wealth uh it's a
lot of good guys just a dude gaming
historian he he's he'll like show you
like old legal battles send video games
I got Nintendo trying to like shut out
black buster
mm-hm you guys know about that no tell
me about that Nintendo tried to make it
so you couldn't rent their games from
Blockbuster I guess that yeah they just
thought renting is gonna cut down on the
purchase price
you know black mustard bias blockbuster
buys a million billion copies yeah but
they you know I never thought how did
renting work back in the day did
Nintendo ever get a kickback from the
rentals or a block to just buy buys them
and then read some no no they probably
you know bought every copy and then paid
an additional royalty to Nintendo
probably I don't know it's with Nintendo
they're just like super protective of
their IP like beyond reasonable measure
it seems like across the board so what
are they getting crazier though like
they're freaking Mario what that rabbit
[Music]
love rabid Peach I was like who what is
these there's this game Alan swish where
it's like a turn base with Mario and
right
know who the rabbit from rains from oh
it's pretty soft well there's a newer
Rayman Origins
no Rayman Raving Rabbids oh there's like
it was a TV show minigame kind of thing
you have a minion vibe don't that they
are a minion okay I guess they came
first they didn't know the rabbits came
first you minions sons of [ __ ] so
wasn't what are they doing with their IP
in that game
you said they're getting worse oh no
it's actually fun oh so they're getting
better no no maybe they did that way
back to you know with a square Mario RPG
what makes a great critic in your mind
um you know just well-spoken
well-thought-out you have to understand
you know what you like you have to
understand why it appeals to you you
know I general like a lot of people when
I made that video some some critics like
they'll message me and say yeah I would
do a review in the my editor wouldn't
give this score you know he would right
through in the editor would say okay
yeah
this score oh that's so crooked what so
that explains why there's a disconnect
between the score you give me I saw this
all the time or in your video and in
general it's like this video this game
gave me literal cancer so weird explain
so do you think that they do that simply
because of some some deal with the
publisher probably you know so much like
IGN their whole their whole setup is you
know they got to get ads it's like a
standalone website it's not in YouTube
right so they got to get their own ads
so they can't piss off the people you
know who puts the ads on IGN game maker
yeah
so can't drive you can't [ __ ] around
with them oh that's such a rough model
yeah III know that youtubers like tech
youtubers get in the same trouble like
they get a lot of [ __ ] like what kind of
tech like phone reviewers oh people like
that or a lot or you know like they'll
get invited to preview a phone before
the general public sure and they're like
if I give it a bad a review are they
gonna revoke my access maybe yeah with
that then you just have to hope that the
audience like recognizes that's what's
going on and you can like pick and
choose which you know critics you listen
to or like how to receive the you know
the score like what it actually means
like a 70 is like it was really bad on
the website 7 is good good 713
that's the worst game this is the top
question from the subreddit so I have to
ask you [ __ ] marry or kill Donkey Kong
Country Super Mario Brothers 2 and knack
do you even know what that game is I
don't think he's ever done one of those
oh yeah you know what you have to choose
one of the three you have to choose
which one you want to [ __ ] which one you
want to marry and which one you want to
kill Donkey Kong Country Super Mario
Brothers 2 and Mac isn't the game or the
character I think they MEA well that's a
fun follow-up disc yeah do you want yeah
okay that even legal say the characters
then alright I guess they have to have
sex with
the human with the game yeah the game
Mario what do you even do with that Love
Finds away yeah like that guy with his
car if you need to reach something so
that means you would kill Mario I
appreciate you taking that relatively
seriously so we're we're marrying that
we're killing a Mario and we're [ __ ]
Donkey Kong I love it okay
I'm glad yeah that was you're a fan of
hip hop right I've noticed you like
referencing hip hop do you let him up
yeah that's some some of your hip hop
head sometimes he's a rapper he really
does I'm Bandcamp you have a full album
uh-huh just like recycled YouTube songs
that he some rap songs from YouTube like
just videos you know where can we find
that people deserve to hear that it's on
Bandcamp donkeys album Jason's pretty
much just Kendrick I love Kendrick yeah
it's the busker what's your favorite
album with his I don't know good kid
maad city damn your boys yeah that's
dope that's probably that's the most
cohesive story I think that one has the
most bangers mm-hmm and it sounds like
the you know a normal that's when I
first heard I was like this is just
normal this is this terrible message you
know like if some more if somebody else
if my mom heard it yeah but if you
actually listen it's like you know a
really positive message it's like the
whole right 180 of what rap is yeah I
love that I love Kendrick I really like
hip-hop it's like musical and his stuff
is very jazzy and musical and I cried
and Mike I mean he's just on top of his
game his lyrics aren't
music how'd you like his new album the
damn uh I was really good
cool he has some really good tracks on
there oh yeah what was your favorite one
last one
Duckworth Oh Duckworth yeah it's crazy
time twister yeah three different beats
it's the craziest [ __ ] ever
do you like that's it always has to
listen to whatever I hear of that kind
of stuff is like his mix that he makes
so he like he edits the songs too
alright don't you like take that part
seriously he edits them like really
deeply and he makes like mix CDs in our
car our car I was like a hundred CDs
what he's editing and made yeah
so there's a song and there's a
particular part you don't like you'll
edit it out and make your own dad
director's cut yeah even with like
Beatles songs I was like what did you do
this choruses I always edit the corner
sound because this is repetitive you're
just like no you guys I want that I want
Jason's director's cut and all these
popular albums I think yeah I didn't you
like distribute it to at least one of my
friends so when you make the cut would
you make sure it sounds sure yeah yeah
with Adobe you can it's written it's
easy man a lot more songs unless there's
like no jazz some songs you just can't
ever do it with it cuz there's so much
stuff in the background but a lot of
songs are just so simple it's just like
you will never know people who have
never heard the song we'd just be like
oh thanks that's real they're like oh
wow there's no course that's how they
make it in the [ __ ] studio they just
clip it right there definitely I've seen
him do it yeah so you can just
to say but to say the chorus once and
loop that right you know rarely ever a
guy will just actually sing it himself
so you just loop their ass right back
out that's harder though with like real
good guys like Prince he would like you
know he would sing the chorus every time
so it's like different a little every
time we have a good prince mix CD in
your favourite band sound like you're
pretty big into music
he's the best man wait I'm not Frank
Ocean she pops Frank Ocean is good - Oh
Frank Ocean you ever listen to Tyler the
Creator Frank Ocean did a cool yeah I
think you'd like it a lot it's great
flower boy I bought his sneakers I like
the blue sneakers it has a B on the back
yeah I love yeah I think that you don't
have to like be a fan of something to
like it like aesthetically yeah minor
he's a yeah he's an expert shoe maker in
my opinion yeah well you know what
meaning you'll always say our dream when
she drops teddy fresh coming in about a
week yeah that's if we ever see someone
on the street wearing like a teddy fresh
piece of clothing and they don't know
who we are don't know I think you can
definitely get there with that that was
good thank you dude appreciate that
do you guys ever follow like big drama
on YouTube like the leafy keemstar items
rice gum whatever crap like do do you
love that or you just don't care I don't
like look at it and be like haha he's so
out of the loop I will have to like
inform him of some things if like I
don't know if it's like sort of related
to him at all but he will never like
look at it himself that is sometimes
some stuff that's it if it's like popped
up at him
yeah he doesn't like seek it out or
anything
I still don't watch jontron because he's
black video was so crazy and again oh my
god I love you still see that comment
Oliver he just finds a good way to like
call stuff out that he sees in him he
just drops it and moves on I got a
question for you
rest in peace Robin Williams or both
[Music]
good all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's choking up Matt Damon she's a good
[Music]
well I suspect that part of this is like
satirical about how people overestimate
the impact of people's death who they'd
ever met well it's you know don't really
want to praise it it's something you
would see on YouTube too like some kid
would make it that's definitely in the
vein of that kid would make you know
that's what they would make their
tribute to Ram Williams right just be
the worst [ __ ] ever
I think you would like to okay yeah I
think Robin would like that too I was
touched by it
especially when you zoomed in undead
[Laughter]
what do you make videos like this or
like one that pops out - my - space
safari loved it I learned it I like this
is that like a troll on fans are you
genuinely just like this is good I just
wanted to have a relaxing space Safari
like something weird just surprise your
audience god bless ya he was into it I
remember when he was making it you took
like a week or so and you were like just
editing the heck out of it you're like
ya gotta get the perfect clip for this
song where did you find all that footage
because you had some incredible yeah a
lot of my videos are I just like cycled
through all these other YouTube stuff
this is like probably three hundred
thousand other videos and Sally's video
that's sometimes they get mad do you
when you when you what when you use
other people's footage yeah I tried to
credit people but there's like you know
there's some money mmm but if they ever
contact now definitely credit them and I
try to credit ones that I use a lot hmm
do you care about your like I know that
some people are not gonna get this like
the space safari one and they're
probably gonna get like butter but do
you you're just like you don't care and
you're make do you feel like you're
making it for yourself or do you how
much do people
oh yeah I guess sometimes you gotta make
you know something new that they won't
expect sometimes you got to play you
know tell what they want give the fans
exactly what sometimes you gotta give
them really well you got to give them
what they want but they don't know they
want that's the trick that's true that
is the trick they probably didn't want
that I was just like man this guy is the
[ __ ]
he'll just he doesn't give a [ __ ] I did
like the video I'm not sayin um what do
you think lately I've been having a hard
time enjoying video games I cannot find
a video game that I like playing since
Zelda and before that I couldn't find
one is it me or is it the state of
gaming like do you what do you think
about the state of gaming uh-huh I think
it's worse than ever you know the worst
[ __ ] is coming out and the best stuff is
coming out mm-hmm maybe just gotta you
know branch out try different stuff that
you wouldn't play normally how do you
find the good stuff how do you sort it
ah yes I'm gonna cook oh that helps
that's all right you just try everything
yeah yeah play a lot of stuff I'm gonna
have to just hit you up on the weekly
I'll do have like a weekly update for
the show
Ducky's recommended game I often look at
the user reviews I find like that's a
badge almost a better indication than
the actual Metacritic score sometimes
yeah you can get a feel but everyone's
taste is so different like me and him my
taste is really different like he'll get
he has a short like patience for games
so if anything is like you know like old
NES games you can't like stick to it to
like beat any of those games just
mononymously idea memorizing yeah if you
read the wrong review it might be the
complete opposite of what your opinion
would be so just try it anyway do you
ever read reviews or do you just look at
the score
nice any of the real bills [ __ ] I don't
know what games have you tried do you
like those kind of games where you just
kind of guides you around like journey
have you ever played that I loved that
game about journey journey was the game
you're laughing at me you hated it I
loved it it was like a magical journey
if you will it was relaxing intuitive I
felt like I was on an adventure I loved
it there's some Abzu ads ooh from the
art director a journey looks like a fish
Oh
what for what console I think that's for
everything switch inside did you guys
try out
no I'm write these down as I'm actually
gonna write Dan just sent you know he
said inside is so [ __ ] good thanks
for the feedback thanks for the light
feed back inside and gazook see you guys
out there take it from me up from from
dunk i was a really short one say it's
really easy to get into is there any
good games on switch cuz i'm like i
played zelda sure loved it what's some
great ones that i need to get on switch
uh-huh I thought that Mario rabbits on
this one yeah I played that a bit that's
pretty fun did you beat it almost okay
the snipper clips game you might like
playing it together there's like this
one and you have to like snipper clip
it's really cute yeah it's like these
little paper like shapes and you have to
work together to like do whatever it
wants you to basically think I sorry we
haven't can you yeah I try that 100
right now this down sip I see people
saying stardew valley Oh
I couldn't I was like it's not for
everyone I loved it so much personally
but I planted a couple turnips games
like that you have to self-direct like
you have to set a goal for yourself like
I love doing stuff like that like I was
even into Minecraft like a lot because I
like to like just decide like I want to
build like this and then you're just
working towards your own goal like he
can't do that at all he wants it all to
me like telling him what to do I guess I
like that yeah well we need to worry
we're the carry
yeah you like started Valley too but in
a different way you didn't play this
much stuff I just I played it for a
couple hours I did really like how it's
like Oh build a farm but then all this
cool other [ __ ] is happening there's a
little Indian the storyline was it
really one dude and concerned eight
concerned at least you guys yeah so what
big games are you looking forward to in
this coming years ahead you're ahead
Mario I'm excited for stardew valley
multiplayer to finally come out oh yeah
they've been like working on it for a
long time together you can destroy each
other's farms that's pretty much all
that was gonna happen
farmville yeah I'm probably gonna set if
you didn't watch it's gonna be bad yeah
that's what happened when we played
Minecraft together you just ruined up
the house can you not it's too tempting
so what are the chances of Mario being
bad I mean let's be real
listen I want to spread here zero zero
percent everyone zero it might not be
you know there's a small percent it
won't be the best destined thing with
Mario it's either the best game of all
time rs is mediocre even if it's the
best [ __ ] ever because it has to come
Mario's this every Mario's like the best
[ __ ] ever
that's so cool yeah it's kind of like
this
old saying about pizza they says or well
he says like pizza is like sex when it's
good it's great and when it's bad it's
still pretty good so Mario so oh let's
take some calls getting towards the end
of this year we got squiggle D doc let's
move it in a squiggle of that talk to me
oh hey magetta you're sorry with your
experience of VR do you guys think VR
will become a gaming standard in the
future or is it just a fad hmm cool nice
question hmm
also Ethan if you have a chance to try
out had in time had in time Mario yeah
it's very inspiring okay cool I'll check
that out thanks buddy
another indicator hm do you think VR is
a passing fad Oh China in the current
state yeah in the current version they
don't go away
yeah but eventually you know once it's
sold like right now it's like it's bulky
and wires go on in like a hundred under
this computer it's like a 50-pound thing
on your head and it makes you all sweaty
it's impressive though oh yeah something
you want to see it and then you're like
okay where am I gonna store all of this
stuff I do that for like an hour
yeah I need a really powerful machine -
yeah and running on that's how I feel
about the vibe yeah
like once super impressive yeah once
they like the hardware's like yeah if
they just like get it refined and you
know it's hard to imagine what they'll
come up with but I mean it's possible
you're getting there yeah indeed the
actual immersive experience you get from
like the vibe is incredible
I think once they get those real games
out there yeah right now it's just
mostly demos yeah I just didn't know
still the valves the lab is the best
game on the art which is just a demo
let's bring it in from you oh I moved
him in the wrong room sorry I did it
probably had a great question oh there
is the best the best go hey hey what's
up how you doing pretty good
so my question was it's a little bit
freaky yet so what was your favorite
console like going all the way back from
the first ones to the current generation
and what was your favorite game for that
console ku ku thanks dude you ready for
that
uh I guess the Nintendo 64 mmm all right
doesn't get better than that Mario 64
banjo-kazooie uh Diddy Kong Racing a lot
of good games I think your favorite is
my sixth super out of yeah - 64 is my
favorite game of all time so I guess I
got to pick down that game was shocking
when I came out yeah it was like what I
remember when I was a kid and I saw it
in the store I was like that was the big
that I think that was a bigger leap than
VR really huh 2d to 3d was just like
what the [ __ ] yeah you're right so was
that the best console the best time in
gaming ever the Nintendo 64 and then you
on the other side you had the
PlayStation which was an awesome I don't
know there's still I feel like it's
better now than ever
no that's nice you seem like a very you
can play all that sit now I'm still out
there that's true I guess nobody's
making you love it I honestly don't have
strong opinion about it I was always a
PC gamer the deepest video game whole
crack whole meme hole I've ever been in
was EverQuest
yeah I was a piece I've always been a PC
gamer but I you know I always played all
those consoles but I never really never
pride me away from ever crack because
you all world of warcraft and you're
like oh yeah
but let me tell you I tried that game
yep yeah that's that's a free game you
gotta do oh yeah you still play ten
years I don't play it like you know all
the time like I would then but I liked
usually for some reason in the winter
cuz I mean we're in Wisconsin yeah I'd
like for the nostalgia and just for
something to do but yeah it seems like a
really cool game I mean for some people
some people just think it's like a
laughing stock but I was always like a
2d MMO just the idea of is pretty what
we're doing yeah I love the graphics
they look like dressing up your
character and all that and so I don't
know it's a more like girly one I guess
I tried to do like wow and other ones
but just couldn't do it know if she
doesn't like the grant if she doesn't
think the game is cute she won't play I
have to be looking at it I agree
it's like offending never really cared
about graphics I just care about having
a good time I got into one game in my
life really nice jumper that's Tetris
that but I was gonna say bagel
that's the game that comes yeah
really I think we've got scammed into
buying it we bought tackle tackle nights
and that was when we were in Santa Cruz
we were dead broke and all we had was an
Xbox and peggle and we like full
completed that let me ask you guys this
we're we're coming here towards the end
what are five games that everybody
should play or not maybe not five but
likes the games that come to mind really
you like games you have to play this
let's go back and forth yeah play that
no way I was gonna say Myra sunshine
I've never played that I see this shot
let me buy it on switch what how do I
play it you can't play any Mario they
gotta bring all that old stuff on this
one that's what I'm saying it's so I am
the Wii right no dusty box yeah yeah you
like Mario Galaxy I did like a that was
nice what else all right Mario Galaxy no
I would say though it started to Valley
too and also Animal Crossing new leaf
that's when I got really into to I have
like three game cartridges for it pop
them out I'd like used to Game Boys at
once once yeah
I took his reminds me of their my
EverQuest days thing called multi boxing
is that what it's come on set up two pcs
and I can have someone Auto healing you
you were multi box I was for animal
crossing money you stole mine
she took my animal crossing cartridges
to put more hair stuff on it
she's like deleted my she got so mad my
guy from Animal Crossing like don't come
in right you don't even get the pic
villager moves into your city and she
could not get rid of it would always
stay there no matter what
two months ruined my town cuz his house
was a big trash can and that was your
guy yeah you came from I came from his
village in the mine
you brought the virus he didn't with you
alright well let's wrap it up as we do
with with many of our guests we asked do
you guys have any ghost stories
paranormal encounters yes we do you do
do you have no spooky alert I have like
two but okay they're not I wouldn't say
they're like ghosts just likes
paranormal kind of stuff okay so the
first one it is like just kind of more
personal to me I don't know if it's like
evidence of any sort of paranormal stuff
but yeah so basically when I was about
11 or 12 I think I was in bed and I was
like about to fall asleep and I was
laying with my back to the wall so like
I was facing the edge of the bed that
was like out to the room you know so I
like open my eyes for some reason and
right like right in front of my face
like two inches away I saw like a big
statue guy I would describe it like kind
of a Tiki head but like also kind of
like Easter Island heads if you know
those statues my knee is just like
staring at me and I was like so scared I
just like froze and then he just said
I'll be back blanket
yeah I was just like frozen until I fell
asleep I guess but yeah just one time
yeah and that's the thing so for me I
like having in my head like I don't
share my brain like conjured it up but
it could do it again so I could see him
again he's a liar
he'll be back he might still be back
they were taunting me it's like a ghost
for me so not like that intense
sometimes I'll wake up from dreaming and
it's like your dream juice is left over
in your brain and you can like
hallucinate yes if you were still
dreaming I'm sure it was something like
that
you got dream juste yeah but it could
happen does it feel like it was
paranormal deal like it did at the time
I was like I know I saw it like I told
my parents and everything I was like I
know he was there like I saw this guy it
was like it was like a stone statue but
yeah no I know it was just like you know
I'm sleeping or whatever but cuz my
brain like I made it up I could just do
it again so yeah yeah well I I don't
know I'm just a dream juice god damn it
you take yes yeah yeah there you go
what are your ghosts alright so he'll
protect you he'll be fine okay I just
didn't know if yeah yeah well my other
one is more like aliens I guess yeah
okay so this one was more recent it was
when I was like going to school in
Arizona College and I was like flying
home for winter break or something and I
was just getting up and we really got
the full height you know for the the
rest of the flight you know we were way
up and I saw I looked out the window and
there was like this black it was like a
blimp I feel like but it was really
shiny so
kind of like a Zeppelin but it didn't
have wings it was just kind of like
coasting along and it was going faster
than our airplane it was moving like
kind of in the same direction as us like
a slightly different angle but it was
going faster than the plane I was like
what is that like blimp going so fast
but it was nighttime what shape it was
daytime Sun was like really shiny on it
yeah so that yeah but I'm like you know
like the logical part of me is like well
if they're flying airplane they know
everything like what's flying up here
with them yeah
like it can't be anything like too crazy
but I know that was really fast I know
stuff like that
yeah I don't know what and and Jason
alien encounters I saw I was mainly to
ask this before we end it because you
guys have just got engaged and it's
wonderful it's adorable I love it and I
was wondering how did you guys meet yeah
Oh kind of an interesting story yes the
short version is that like I knew him
from his videos I was like a fan of his
videos yeah the rest of it is like a
little bit creepy like we were both kind
of crazy not like but ya know I saw one
of his videos and he was like at the
Museum so it was like Night at the
Museum or something and it was really
funny video but I noticed that it was a
museum that I had been to so I was like
this guy lives it great by me like I'm
gonna really I'm in Wisconsin - I just
added him on skype now this is the part
where he was creepy no I just typed his
name in
yeah
I added like there was only two that
came up so I was just like and friend
add friend yeah he accepted because he
would go through and look for girls you
know it's not that work dolly like yeah
it's kind of like a recipe for something
like that wouldn't work I I know what
you probably added like a thousand girls
are yeah we played games together online
for a while before we met in person yeah
we just started hanging out I think
that's cool I think that's a wonderful
beautiful tale of love triumphing
against odds and also insights memories
of was Robin Williams and guys it was a
joy as a player privilege and an honor
to have you guys thanks for coming with
us so guys thanks for watching I hope
you had fun and enjoyed it I'm gonna put
up the thread for questions for next
week for a [ __ ] Aryan that's it that's
all she wrote for this week so thank you
guys for watching and appreciate Jason
is turning and facing the wall Lee is
following suit can we get off shot and
these know basically Dan our producer
was like listen when they're not talking
directly towards you you need to face
the wall because it's awkward for them
and we don't like people to look them in
the eyes so they're they're great guests
they're the best guess anyway guys love
you all yeah and have a great week
thanks I saw it Europeans getting
triggered that I says thanks for
spending your day with us thank you for
spending your day with us Americans
those of you in Europe
you're spending your evening with us it
means your late night whatever time of
day it is
thank you god damn it super early
morning thank you everybody out there
anyway guys see you next week
Tata
[Music]